the Skywalker storyline comes to an end
with Star Wars the rise of Skywalker and
that's too bad because there are plenty
of stories about the most famous family
in the galaxy far far away from pirate
adventures to clone craziness here are
the best Skywalker stories we'll never
see in the movies
though there were rumors of a turn to
the dark side for Luke Skywalker leading
up to the last Jedi such a turn never
took place
Luke remained even in his disillusioned
state - bastion for good he got to save
the day with his force projection duel
against kylo Ren which allowed the
resistance fighters to escape and prove
that Luke remained a true hero to his
core but fans of the expanded universe
know that Luke was previously tempted by
the dark side going so far as to become
the apprentice to the Emperor himself I
got a bad feeling about this
the storyline occurred in one of the
first expanded universe stories the
aptly named dark empire this 1991 comic
book from Dark Horse Comics takes place
just a handful of years after Return of
the Jedi and it sees the Emperor
returned from his presumed death at the
end of that film for the explanation
being that he transferred his
consciousness to a cloned body at the
moment of his death
Luke shocked to see him alive agrees to
become his apprentice with his plan
being to bring down the resurgent Empire
from the inside but the darkside
corrupts Luke and he loses sight of his
goal
it takes a lightsaber fight against Leia
for him to snap out of it and at that
point he's finally able to defeat
Palpatine dark Luke would have been cool
to see on the big screen but the window
for this story closed long ago and the
official Star Wars sequel films Luke is
not shown to have settled down as far as
we know he never had a serious
relationship never married and never had
children butting the expanded universe
Luke did all of those things with a
woman named Mary Jade Mara Jade was
introduced in the 1991 novel heir to the
Empire the first installment in Timothy
Zahn's wildly popular Thrawn Trilogy
Mara is introduced as a smuggler who was
previously employed as the Emperor's
hand she's an extremely skilled user of
the dark side of the force and prior to
the Emperor's death Mara was given the
command to kill Luke Skywalker she
manages to kidnap Luke but the two
subsequently become stranded in a harsh
environment and must work together to
escape this event starts to bring the
two together and though it takes several
more novels Luke and Mara eventually
fall in love and
get married in the 2000 Dark Horse
Comics Star Wars union that's not the
end of their story Luke and Mara also
have a son together named Ben Skywalker
whose first name appears to have been
recycled in the sequel trilogy as Ben's
solo
aka kylo Ren Ben Skywalker grows up to
become an accomplished Jedi like his mom
but Mara doesn't live to see it she's
murdered by her nephew Jason solo while
he's on his way to becoming Darth Titus
Mara Jade wasn't the only character of
significance to be introduced in zones
Thrawn Trilogy there was also Luke
Skywalker with to use an evil clone who
made his debut in the conclusive novel
in the trilogy the last command in the
story it's revealed that the clone was
created by the mad Jedi Master Jorah
Sabbath Sabbath made the clone using
Luke severed hand that Darth Vader cut
off during their battle on Cloud City
and the Empire Strikes Back and Luke
even wielded Luke's original lightsaber
that was also lost in that battle sigh
by all six Luke on Luke and the two
engage in an intense lightsaber duel
given that Luke is a genetic clone of
Luke and that he's received expert
training from Sabaoth the two are a
perfect match for each other their fight
ends when resident badass Mara Jade
intervened it's using Leia's lightsaber
to slay both Luke and Joris saibai off
the real Luke comes to view Luke as the
Pavillon of the vision he had on Dagobah
and the Empire Strikes Back where he
duels someone he thinks is Darth Vader
only to realize it was himself Luke
Skywalker may not have featured heavily
in the expanded universe but the idea of
an evil Luke clone whose creation came
about thanks to one of the most iconic
scenes in the franchise is undeniably
awesome
not every Skywalker story in the
expanded universe revolved around Luke
Leia also got some love in the EU and
she got to do some pretty cool stuff in
the books and comics that her on-screen
counterpart could only dream of and one
of Laius best stories that will never
make it to the big screen is the
adventure she took in Marvel Comics Star
Wars number 73 which was published
roughly two months after the release of
Return of the Jedi in 1983 the story
dubbed flaws Bane after the planet on
which it takes place picks up not long
after the Battle of Endor Leia Luke
Lando Chewbacca r2d2 and c3po are all
still hanging out together though Han
Solo had gone missing at the time and
I recently picked up a new ally a pink
skin female thief named Danny the gang
heads to the planet Lau's Maine to
search for the flight record of a rebel
pilot who crashed there and they learned
the records they need are located across
a vast canyon Leia and Danny hatch a
plan to secretly secure the records
themselves so under cover of night the
two women cross the canyon and a pair of
hot-air balloons okay yes this story is
ridiculous but the idea of Leia going on
a female-only adventure to prove her
worth even in a hot-air balloon would
have been fun to see on the silver
screen if there's one thing Star Wars
desperately needs it's a Jedi pirate and
that's exactly what kate skywalker is
debuting in Dark Horse's Star Wars
legacy comics Kate story takes place
many years after the exploits of our
traditional Star Wars heroes over a
hundred years after in fact as kate is
the great-great grandson of luke
skywalker
and since canon Luke had no children
that means we'll never see a Kade
Skywalker movie and that's a shame
Cade Skywalker is downright awesome
there's no getting around it the guy is
basically a cross between Luke and Han
with a little Boba Fett's and Jack
Sparrow thrown in for good measure you
are without doubt the worst pirate I've
ever heard of but you have heard of me
he was raised a Jedi but after seeing
his father murdered he takes a different
path by operating in the seedier side of
the galaxy
he becomes a pirate and a bounty hunter
and he has his own sweet ship with a
loyal crew of scallywags
Kate eventually is confronted with his
past when he's discovered by the Sith
Lord Darth krayt who seeks him out due
to his skywalker heritage kate ends up
reluctantly embracing his jedi roots and
proves to be an extremely powerful horse
user taking the fight to create and
eventually killing him in combat Cade
Skywalker story is one of the --use most
thrilling adventures and it would give
Star Wars fans something they hadn't
seen in a movie before but alas it seems
like they never will check out one of
our newest videos right here Plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff or coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you
[Music]